[Music]
scientists work on the boundaries of the
unknown where every new piece of
knowledge forms a path into a void of
uncertainty and nothing is more
uncertain or potentially enlightening
than a paradox throughout history
paradoxes have threatened to undermine
everything we know and just as often
they've reshaped our understanding of
the world today one of the biggest
paradoxes in the universe threatens to
unravel the fields of general relativity
and quantum mechanics the black hole
information paradox to understand this
paradox we first need to define what we
mean by information typically the
information we talk about is visible to
the naked eye
for example this kind of information
tells us that an apple is red round and
shiny but physicists are more concerned
with quantum information this refers to
the quantum properties of all the
particles that make up that Apple such
as their position velocity and spin
every object in the universe is composed
of particles with unique quantum
properties this idea is evoked most
significantly in a vital law of physics
the total amount of quantum information
in the universe must be conserved
even if you destroy an object beyond
recognition its quantum information is
never permanently deleted and
theoretically knowledge of that
information would allow us to recreate
the object from its particle components
conservation of information isn't just
an arbitrary rule but a mathematical
necessity upon which much of modern
science is built but around black holes
those foundations get shaken when an
apple enters a black hole it seems as
though it leaves the universe and all
its quantum information becomes
irretrievably lost however this doesn't
immediately break the laws of physics
the information is out of sight but it
might still exist within the black holes
mysterious void alternatively some
theories suggest that information
doesn't even make
get inside the black hole at all seen
from outside it's as if the apples
quantum information is encoded on the
surface layer of the black hole called
the event horizon as the black hole's
mass increases the surface of the event
horizon increases as well so it's
possible that as a black hole swallows
an object it also grows large enough to
conserve the object's quantum
information but whether information is
conserved inside the black hole or on
its surface the laws of physics remain
intact until you account for Hawking
radiation discovered by Stephen Hawking
in 1974 this phenomenon shows that black
holes are gradually evaporating over
incredibly long periods of time black
holes
lose mass as they shed particles away
from their event horizons critically it
seems as though the evaporating
particles are unrelated to the
information the black hole encodes
suggesting that a black hole and all the
quantum information it contains could be
completely erased does that quantum
information truly disappear if not where
does it go while the evaporation process
would take an incredibly long time the
questions it raises for physics are far
more urgent the destruction of
information would force us to rewrite
some of our most fundamental scientific
paradigms but fortunately in science
every paradox is an opportunity for new
discoveries researchers are
investigating a broad range of possible
solutions to the information paradox
some have theorized that information
actually is encoded in the escaping
radiation in some way we can't yet
understand others have suggested that
paradox is just a misunderstanding of
how general relativity and quantum field
theory interact respectively these two
theories describe the largest and
smallest physical phenomena and they're
notoriously difficult to combine some
researchers argue that a solution to
this and many other paradoxes will come
naturally with a unified theory of every
but perhaps the most mind-bending theory
to come from exploring this paradox is
the holographic principle expanding on
the idea that the 2d surface of an event
horizon can store quantum information
this principle suggests that the very
boundary of the observable universe is
also a 2d surface encoded with
information about real 3d objects if
this is true it's possible that reality
as we know it is just a holographic
projection of that information if proven
any of these theories would open up new
questions to explore while still
preserving our current models of the
universe but it's also possible that
those models are wrong either way this
paradox has already helped us take
another step into the unknown ever
wonder if a black hole could destroy us
or we could destroy a black hole cast
your lot for or against humanity by
watching one of these videos next
[Music]